this course will increase your knowledge
of JavaScript node.js apis react
databases and more Anya Kubo is your
instructor she'll show you how to build
the same project using three different
methods and this will help you gain a
deeper understanding of each method
hey everyone and welcome to this
compilation video which we're going to
build the same
three times
so we're actually going to go to the
flight widget we're going to start off
super easy we're going to start off
building this and vanilla JavaScript so
if you're a beginner this is the perfect
one for you okay we're going to build
the widget and then we're going to
display data onto it onto these flipping
little cards right here and get new data
every so often
next up I'm going to show you how to
essentially build this by using an API
I'm actually going to build it in
JavaScript for the front end and show
you how to build a node.js backend in
order to get data from the API that
we're going to use okay so this one
right here this is real data this is the
real stuff
and finally I'm going to show you how to
build the same thing but using react at
this time I'm going to show you how to
use react for the front end and then a
database with our own data to pretending
we're at the airport and we're updating
this data I'm going to show you how to
get that data Again by building a
node.js backend and using this free
database so you don't need any credit
cards or anything like that
so I'm excited let's do it
okay so let's get to building Australia
flight widgets so no apis for this one
this is going to be super vanilla
JavaScript for those of you learning
JavaScript however if you do want to
learn how to do it with an API please do
check out the link in my description
below but we're going to do the same
project however using an API so it's
either project for whatever level you
feel comfortable with
let's do it so first off I am using web
store so this means I can just open up
my wet storm and create a new project
and I'm just going to choose to call
this flight with jet vanilla JavaScript
and then click create okay so there we
go you will see a directory has been
created for me and all I'm going to do
is create a new file an HTML file which
can be an index HTML file just choose
HTML5 right here or if you're not using
website you might need to type.html to
give your file
the HTML extension so that your code
editor knows to treat it like an HTML
file so there we go there's my HTML file
with the boilerplate thank you or
webstorm and I'm just going to call this
flight
widget
just like so the next thing we need to
do is create an app.js file and a style
sheet so Styles CSS once again I'm just
going to choose to select the dot CSS
file so if you haven't got a web store
make sure to put dot CSS to make sure
that your code editor treats this as a
CSS file
and once again I'm just going to create
a JavaScript file and call this app and
once again make sure to have the dot JS
extension if you are not using webstorm
okay great
so now first things first let's go ahead
and connect our style sheet using the
link tag it's a self-closing tag and all
I'm going to do is make sure that this
is going to the path of where we keep
our Star sheet as it's in the root of
our project along with our index.html
file so the same location I could just
type in the file name like so we don't
need to go into any directories or
anything like that
and once again I'm going to use the
script tag like this and use Source in
order to get our app.js files so again
the same way that we went and got our
CSS file we're just typing in the file
name as it's in the same level it's in
the same directory so we don't need to
go finding it in different folders it's
just there so we use the file name
great now this is a JavaScript tutorial
so we're going to be writing very
limited HTML on purpose for this so the
only HTML I'm really going to have is a
div
that's going to I'm going to give this
the class of
departures so that we can see it and we
can style it up a little bit and I'm
actually going to have let's just have a
header why not like so
and then I'm going to have a table now
my table well I'm going to hard code the
head of the table so if you haven't used
tables before you have the table tags
that take another tag called T head for
the header and then T body these are
optional I like to keep my header and my
body of the table separate especially
for this tutorial it will really help us
out a lot
this is because I'm going to give the
tea body an ID
of table body so that we can pick this
out and then inject table rows into here
using JavaScript so like I said I'm
going to hard code the header the table
header but this is all going to have
injected JavaScript I'm going to show
you how to do that it's really exciting
let's do it
so here is the Syntax for a uh table you
have the table
row
so you have two table row tags like that
and then the table row is going to well
as this is the table uh header I'm going
to use th but these will have TD so the
first table header is going to say time
and then I'm actually going to pick this
out as well so I'm going to give this
the idea of time because we're going to
want to
give this some custom styling later
as well as other things this is going to
be destination
destination
and then we have th
I'm gonna have
flight
then we're also going to have the Gate
of the flight
and then it's also have the
remarks so once again let's give all of
these an ID so this will be Destination
Unknown Known destination then we're
gonna have ID of
flights and I'm gonna have ID of
Gates
and this one's going to be ID
of
remarks okay so that's hard-coded and
all of this we're going to be injecting
with JavaScript so let's go ahead and do
that by picking out this table body
element by the ID so in here I'm going
to use document
get element by ID
and look for the table body
just
like
so
okay so once we have that I'm gonna
actually save it as const table body so
that we can work with it easier in our
JavaScript and just get rid of that
great so the first thing first as we are
just you know this is just for fun I'm
just going to use an array of data for
this so uh let flights I'm using let for
a reason which will become more apparent
later as this we will want to change
this
so each of my flights is essentially
going to be represented by an object and
that is going to have a time so here is
my first
flights going off at 8 11 A.M its
destination is going to be uh a month
the flight number is going to be
ox
203
the gate number is going to be a01
and the remarks is going to be that it's
on time okay so that is one I'm not
gonna uh just sit here allow you to
watch me type these out I have pre-made
this
so here are all my flights we have Oman
we've got a flight to London that's been
canceled Dubai Frankfurt and Tokyo okay
so those are my flights I have or I will
be putting the code in the description
of this video if you want to take that
or if you want to you know take this
video and just pause it while you write
this down it's totally up to you
whichever version you prefer but yes I
will be sharing the final code with you
in the description below
okay so those are all our flights this
is what we're going to be using in order
to create our flight widget
so
in order to populate our widget with
this information I'm going to write a
function called populate
table
just like so
and we're going to be using uh
for Loops to do this and I'm going to
say that four so obviously this is
called Flights I want to Loop for as
many flights as we have so again this is
one flight this is one flight we have
one two three four five there's gonna
look five times and we can do so with
this syntax so flights is the name of
our array const flight of flight so
we've now defined that one of these is a
flight
and all I'm going to do is for each
flight I'm going to use document to
create an element and that element is
going to be a table row so once we have
done that let's actually save this as
const table row
great
so as it stands for each of these we
have created a table row so just like we
see here a table Row the next thing we
need to do is actually create a table or
a TD
to hold all of this information so for
each one of these lines we need to
create a TD element right
so let's do that document
create
element
TD and I'm going to save this as const
so let's do that so we've done that and
the next thing we need to do well
actually let's put this in to our table
body first
so I'm going to get the table body and
use append
to append the table row
into our table bodies so each time this
Loop is going to go into the tail what
do you put in a table row put in a table
row do that five times
okay so that is being put in however
before we put that in we want to create
the five uh TD elements so let's make
another loop for this for this time
we're going to look in here
so we're going to look in the flight
look in the flight because we're working
with objects this time I'm going to get
the flight details so we are saying
let's define each of these lines or
sorry to be more precise each of these
as a flight detail
okay so all I'm going to do now is use
document create element
TD and then const table cell that's what
I'm going to call it so we're creating a
table cell and now what we want to do
is essentially well we can
I'm just going to console log for you
what this looks like console log the
flight detail
and of course we need to call this
function
so it's looking
here I can just use this button because
we are using webstorm or for those of
you not using webstorm you just need to
get the absolute pass I'm going to copy
the path at the absolute path and then
in the browser I'm just going to paste
it in like so it's the same thing and
now if we inspect the page you will see
here's our body there's the div that we
made called departures there's our
hard-coded header and there's the body
and we have injected five table rows as
we said
okay
five table rows
and the next thing we said we want to do
is put in the table data right and that
table data based on the flight details
so as you will see here the flight
details that are just the essentially
the keys we want the values so flight
gate remarks so if I was just to
use the flight detail for example if I
get the table
sell in a text flight detail and then of
course we need to actually get the table
set and put it in the table row so table
row append child or pen whichever one
you want table cell it would just look
like this we don't want that we actually
want to get the
value
so we do so
by doing
by getting the objects and then opening
up the array and finding it based on the
flight detail so we're looking in here
I'm going our destination and that will
return the value
just do this instead
okay
so that will give us the actual flight
details
cool
you think this is pretty much
well wrong because this is at the moment
just all one word I don't want that I
actually want to split out each letter
so that we can flip each one and I want
to put each one onto a div essentially
so that's the next thing that we are
going to do so to do this I essentially
need to make an array of all the uh
letters
so
instead of doing this here
let's get the word and I'm going to use
array from
this essentially
so we don't need this anymore so we're
getting the word but obviously the words
all like
split up into an array it's an array of
all the letters
and now for each letter so again we're
going to use four const
a letter
of word this time
um
we're going to create
an element and it's going to be a
div
however
yeah that's fine we're going to create a
div and then let's save this as letter
element
so we've got our letter element
and then
we're going to just get the letter
element
uh classless ads we're going to add the
class of flip and then the letter
element text content is just going to be
letter
right so now if we look in here
we of course need to put that in because
we haven't
done that yet we're gonna
get the table
sell append
letter element
go
so it looks like this it looks a bit
like Matrix so let's do some styling
so what do or we want to do so let's go
to Starship up
now I'm going to use a Google font for
this
the font is uh condensed Ubuntu
so I'm just going to get rid of that
Ubuntu
Ubuntu sorry Ubuntu kubuntu condensed
and I'm just gonna select well there's
actually one so it's easy I'm going to
use this version to import it into the
style sheet directly not into my HTML
but you can of course choose to do
whatever you wish
now for all everything in here I'm going
to choose the font family Ubuntu
so this one and as a backup Sans serif
so I'm just going to paste that in here
like so I'm going to say that all the
text I want to be like an off-white so
I'm going to do that
now and the font size is going to be
font size sorry
it's going to be 35 pixels
okay and then the body of the whole app
itself well I just want to Center
everything so I'm going to use display
Flex so I'm initializing the flexbox and
then I'm justifying content Center so
you can't use this line without
initializing flexbox just be aware of
that I'm going to give a height to the
body because I then also want to align
items Center and you can't do this
without giving it a height so just keep
that in mind and let's make the
background color
um
I'm gonna do two five one one nine nine
one two seven
great and now the header we did have a
header so I'm just going to give that
some padding of 10 pixels and then we
also named the div that holds everything
we gave it the class so dot for class of
Departures right so dot class of
departures
and I'm gonna give this a background
color of RGB
666
and let's round it off because I do like
a border radius to make it seem
kind of like softer I guess border
radius
10 pixels and then padding 10 pixels and
then we could add some box Shadow later
but I'm not going to do that now
let's also get the departures uh and say
that any table that exists in the div
with the class of Departures is going to
have a background color of RGB
46 46
46. and I'm going to do text align
left
so let's see what this looks like so far
Okay so we've done that we just need to
go into the TD and make sure that
everything's kind of aligned next to
each other as well
so I think that's because of the T
or it could be done on the div
okay so I'm gonna say that any
TD element that lives in the table that
also lives in the div with a class of
Departures dot for class is going to
have a border
Solid 4 pixels RGB so this is each cell
right
and let's give it a background color
of black
actually
we should be doing this on the
divs themselves so on each of this div I
want to make sure that each div is kind
of like a black it has a little border
Square
so obviously that looks really weird at
the moment and this should be black
sorry
let's make it black and let's make them
all float left
okay there we go
so that's a lot better that is looking
so so good I'm also going to actually
assign this a height just in case you
know there isn't something there I don't
want it to kind of look weird so I'm
just going to hard code that there and
I'm also going to do the same for the
actual uh whole cell that this lives in
so a TD so like one of these TD
cell right so let's hardcore that too so
every TD
is going to have a height of 50 pixels
no matter what
cool
so great and now one last thing I'm
going to do is actually pick out so in
here I'm going to pick each of these out
by its ID and then just space them out a
little bit more because I think they're
a little bit too loose together so the
hash is for ID
so ID of time is going to have a
hard-coded width of 160 pixels no matter
what
and then
uh destination
and also going to have a hard-coded
width
of 260 pixels no matter what
and then we also have
the flight
it's gonna have a width of two or five
pixels
and then the gates we which is going to
have a width of 135 pixels
and then I think we have one more
remarks
remarks
just gonna have a width of 260 pixels
okay
so now that just looks a little bit
better I believe
okay so that's what it looks like I
think it's just a little bit spaced out
a little bit nicer
wonderful
so the next thing I want to do is just
add a flip animation so we've already
added the class of flip to each of these
divs that hold a letter each of our word
so now let's get the class dot for class
of flip
and I'm going to add an animation to it
so the animation is going to last for
0.5 seconds it's going to be a linear
animation
linear and the animation we're going to
call flipping so we have to call it this
and now it means
flipping we have to define it
so I'm just going to say that a zero
percent
uh I'm going to transform it so that it
rotates on the X
oops
rotate X
it's going to start at zero degrees and
then we're going to do
50 it's going to be
90 degrees on the X
axis and then at 100 it's going to go
back to zero
great so that this means if I now
refresh this
the flipping however I want it to look
more like you know it's going
which means we need to put on a set
timeout so I'm going to show you how to
do that now
so when we add the class of flip for
each letter
so for each of these I want this one to
start first and then after a certain
amount of time this one so basically
create essentially let's see if I want
this one to be at 100 milliseconds then
this one to be at 200 milliseconds and
this one to start at 300 and then sort
of 400 milliseconds or just however many
letters we have right we need a loop for
this so in here I'm going to uh we'll
put a set timeout to start a kind of
loop in a way because this set time out
well first off it's gonna go after 100
milliseconds but then I'm going to
multiply it by either 0 1 2 3 or 4
whichever index of this we are on
whichever index of the loop we are on
and this is kind of tricky to do with
the four const of but you can
do it it's actually why I turn this into
an array because you can't do this on an
object
uh if this is an array we can get the
two uh the entries method and use it on
here which means we can now add an index
to this
and we can access the index of the loop
okay so that's how I did that that's a
little bit of advanced JavaScript
hacking I guess I don't know if it's a
hack for you so now we've got a set
timeout that will uh essentially execute
on zero then 100 and then 200 300
milliseconds and all I want to
essentially do
is add the class of flip after that
amount of time and then add the letter
and then put it in the cell
okay so that's all I am doing I don't
know why it's not like what's happening
here oh comma
great
so now maybe let's actually put this all
together so it's a little bit easier
to read
this is my populate
table
function
so now it looks like this
so this is looking
great really I'm going to show you how
to do one more thing just for fun and
that is delete the first line and add a
new random line with a time that is
essentially going up and if it gets
close to midnight then that time reset
so it looks like it's going on forever
and ever and ever without you having to
do anything or add new data because
we're going to use some under two arrays
to either pick out the destination
or the remark and this we're going to
generate with random letters or numbers
and this we're going to increment
with time okay
so let's do it so const destination like
I said this is just for fun right
what kind of destinations be we can have
Tokyo we can have Frankfurt we can have
Dubai we can have
London
let's also have Oman
and let's have
Beirut
see the desk
to Nations
and then let's also have remarks so
we'll only have three remarks possible
uh on time delayed and
canceled
great and then let's start with the hour
being
uh 15.
just because we're on the 15th hour here
last
okay so now let's write a function
called
let's make some space
um
function
Shuffle Up Shuffle Up
and what do we want to happen well we're
going to get the flights array and we're
going to get rid of the first one using
the JavaScript method of shift so that
will literally get rid of this first
item in the array and then to add a new
item we're going to get the flights
array and we're going to use push I'm
going to push in something to the end of
the array so what we're going to push in
is an object so hence I have this and
the destination well let's actually have
the same structure as we have here
so here's our object and I'm going to
push in a time which I'm going to write
actually a function called generate
time to do this destination well that's
just going to be I'm going to go into
destinations array I just wrote and pass
through
so destinations array we're going to
open up our array we're going to pass
through a random number based on the
array length so we can do so easily I
can
get the destinations length
and I can multiply it by math random
and that will give me a random number
anywhere from 0 to this destinations
destiny
anyway so just under the length but then
I need to
sorry yeah just under the so for example
if there's nine things right it will
come back with 8.9 but of course there's
no such thing as index 8.9 we have to
round it down to index 8 to get to the
ninth item so that's why I need to round
it down using math
floor
just like so the next thing we need to
do is um
what we can do actually is the same for
remarks so go into the remarks and then
thank you very much uh get the remarks
length multiplied by math random and
just pass through math flows around it
down and that will return a remark from
the remarks all right
the next thing we need to do is actually
write a function called
generate
Run Dom letter okay and this is going to
generate a random letter for us that
will help us write our flight and gate
randomly so to generate a random letter
I'm going to say well first we need the
alphabet right we need to actually
choose
uh A B C D E F G H I J K L M N M
okay so there we go thank you but I'm
going to get rid of these we just want
capitals
so that's my array and I'm just going to
return a letter randomly so I'm going to
get alphabet
uh Char at
and then instead of at zero I'm going to
pause through once again I'm going to
get the alphabet
length
I'm going to multiply it by math
random and I'm going to pass it through
math flow so that it returns back a
random character from the string okay
but only based on you know however long
this is you don't want to be picking out
something here on the nothing exists
right or throughout errors
so that's how we generate a random
letter which means we can now use it for
here so for example Generate random
letter and then we're going to generate
a random
number
plus again generate a random number with
this space in between so let's just add
a space
like so and of course we need to write
the function generator random number so
function Generate random
number this time it's going to be
exactly the same as we did up here so
I'm literally going to copy this but
this time we're going to choose zero one
two three four five six seven eight nine
which means that we're going to return
and let's call this numbers we're going
to return numbers
based on the numbers
string let
great so that's how we would generate a
random number so let's replace this so
for a flight we're gonna generate a
random letter plus another random letter
plus maybe
an empty string and then some numbers
right so maybe let's have two numbers
again it's up to you
whatever you want
wonderful and now one last one we're
going to write a function to generate
time this isn't so much random so I've
left out the random because we're going
to use the current time in order to
uh or the current hour in order to make
sure that the hours are increasing
so I'm going to get the hour well first
off I'm gonna use let's display our I'm
going to assign the value of hour to it
which we have assigned as 15 above here
15 just because we're on the 15th hour
here
so once we have that if
the hour is smaller than 24
well then that's fine we just want to
increase one to the hour right
and then if
our
is
then suddenly larger than or equal to 24
well then we want the hour to go back to
being hour one
and then we can show that the display
hour is the hour
right okay and if
our is smaller than
well the display hour is gonna we're
gonna add a zero
to it and the hour because we don't want
to be one which wouldn't be zero one or
zero two zero or zero nine so that is
some logic that we have to do before we
can return the display hour
plus the string of this and then we can
just use Generate random number plus
Generate random number uh we don't need
this however the second
number can only be Max up to
5 right
so maybe if we pass through a Max number
into the
generate number functions So Max number
we can say that if a Max number exists
well then
I'm going to get the numbers I'm going
to slice 0 by Max number and make a new
array so constant new numbers
and that's what I want to
return but only if there's a Max number
to return
this by the new numbers
length
okay
so this is looking good and the shuffle
up how often do we want this to happen
so we want to get rid of the first one
we want to add something else to the
array which is going to be our new
object
um and then we want to essentially
redraw the table but the table body we
want to clear it right if anything
that's in there at the moment otherwise
we'll just keep adding more items to it
so I'm going to go text content nothing
and then I'm going to call it populate
table function again
so now let's put this on a set interval
because I want the shuffle ARP to run
I'm going to shuffle up to run every
200 sorry 2 000 milliseconds or every
two seconds so let's check it out
so there's one two and one should
disappear
uh we're getting some errors
Max number oops
this should be new numbers sorry
new numbers because we just made a new
array
okay so and mine should disappear
London appears beirut's been generated
frankfurt's been generated London's been
generated and you will see the time is
going up by the hour let's just check it
goes up to well and just as long as it
stays under 24 we're fine
okay so it's actually stopping at 23
I mean I'm cool with that maybe that
makes our lives easier and this number's
not going above five either
I wonder if it can be five or if we need
to change that because five should
technically be allowed I don't see a
problem with that we've had an error
here already
okay
so this is looking good however
we just need to maybe make this smaller
than and then Max
number
slice it at Max number plus one just so
it includes the five
and let's check it out
so now
should see it
you should see fives showing up in here
five there's a five and it should go up
to 23 but not go over oh no
this is going above 24. okay it's
smaller than or equal to
equal to 24.
and great so it's resetting let's just
leave it as this I'm happy with that
again this is just for fun remember so I
hope you're enjoying this you can have
have your very own I'm just going to
slow this down a little bit as it is
very fast you can have your own
departures table just like so okay
great so I hope you've enjoyed this
tutorial
um please feel free to mess around with
this as much as you like uh take it it's
yours and if you want to see how to
incorporate actual data not just made up
data that we're generating randomly then
please do watch my tutorial on this in
the description below
thanks very much and I'll see you on my
channel
okay so let's do this let's start off on
the rapid API Hub where I'm gonna get my
flight API so please go ahead and sign
up as I've already signed up I'm going
to log in and I can do so with my Google
account so that's what I'm just going to
do I'm just going to go ahead and log in
with Google of course you don't have to
that is just my choice
now the first thing you're gonna have to
do is do a little bit of configuration
which I've done but I'm gonna walk you
through it in order to use the API and
that API that we're going to use there's
actually loads of flight apis there's in
fact just so many apis in general but
the one that we're going to use is of a
specific airport we can use we could do
Madrid's airport to find out what kind
of arrivals and destinations they have
or we can do Toronto so it's totally up
to you for this tutorial though I am
going to go with Toronto's Airport and
this is cool like with every API on
rapid API I'm just going to show you it
here
you get a little dashboard like this and
you get the code
so you get the code required in order to
for example here I can search an
endpoint we're going to want to get the
departures by get all departures so if I
click on get all departures from Pearson
Airport this is the code that I would
need to put in my node.js backend in
order to get the departure details and
if we want to see the example response
without signing up we could just see
what this will come back as you can see
it comes back as an array of objects and
each object represents a departure okay
with the terminal the gate the time is
departing the airline flight number
destination and status as well so this
is what it would look like if I ran this
code and the best thing about this is
that you know we can just use one API
key one API key to control them all in
the rapid API Hub so that is pretty cool
oh so I'm going to show you how to
essentially subscribe to this you're
going to have to put in some details
like your billing details and so on now
most of these apis are free some will
charge you but this will only charge you
charges you if you go over 5 000
requests per day I think which we're not
going to go over don't worry so just go
ahead and under my apps
you'll go to the developer dashboard and
here is where you're going to have to
put in your billing information so under
billing information you'll see I've
already done this please go ahead and
add that here add your billing
information save it and then we can go
back to the API of course you can do a
bunch of other things in here too you
can also make your own API but we're not
going to do that once you put in your
billing information please go back to
the Toronto Pearson API
and we're just going to test the
endpoint so as we said the endpoint we
want is to get all departures and then
this is the code we're going to need
with one API that controls them all so
that is my X rapid API key
I'm going to test the endpoint
uh and
great
so that is what we're getting back these
are the current departures at Pearson
Airport which is pretty cool now I'm
just going to actually take this code
snippet there is of course all these
other languages but we are using node.js
for this tutorial so I'm just going to
copy this so first off we need to
actually create a project
so let's go ahead and do that what I'm
going to do is get up my webstorm
please feel free to use whatever code
edits you wish webstorm is just my
choice of code editor or technically IDE
that I'm going to use for this tutorial
now in here what I'm going to do is just
create a new project so this is going to
have let's have the front end just in
plain or the vanilla JavaScript because
I have made this project before in plain
old vanilla JavaScript and in this one
I'm going to show you how to essentially
make a backend for it in order to get
data from Rapid API so I'm going to go
ahead and create a new project let's
call this
flight
with jet
live
and let's just go ahead and click create
and that will be created in my webstorm
directory okay where I store all my
other projects please feel free to
create a directory whatever directory
you wish
so once that is done we're just gonna
have to create some new files so we know
that we're going to have an HTML file
I'm going to call this index.html
so there we go we also need a
style sheet I'm going to call this
Styles and I'm going to you can either
write CSS but in webstorm I can just say
that this is CSS file and that extension
will be added for me and finally we also
need some JavaScript so let's go ahead
and put in a Javascript file so we've
got an index HTML style sheet and app.js
file
great now let's go ahead and put in some
code into the index HTML page to get
started so let's just go ahead and put
in the title for this fast
so there we go flight widget so we're
going to have to do a few things here
we're going to link this up so we're
going to use the link tag and we're just
going to put this means a little bigger
so everyone can see
Style
sheet and then we are going to add the
href to the Styles CSS file okay it's in
the root so that's all we have to do
next let's also put the script tag in so
we're going to put a script tag in so
that we can essentially connect this
app.js file to here so we're going to
read everything above the body blue and
then we're going to read this which will
take us to the app.js file and then read
all the JavaScript
so the first thing we're going to do is
actually create our table this can be
static I'm not going to be changing
anything with JavaScript here which is
why I'm just going to make it in the
HTML file
it's actually just
style this out a little bit more so just
have the correct indentations
so
yep
okay so now in this div this div I'm
just going to give this a class of
Departures as it's going to hold all our
departures and we're going to make a
table now so let's use table
and then in our table well of course
we're going to have a table head so this
is going to give semantic meaning to our
browsers that this is the table head and
then this is the table body and in the
table head I'm going to well yes we can
actually hard code this it's the table
body that we're going to want to insert
stuff into with JavaScript so how do we
make a header get well we need a row so
let's create a row and in the row we're
going to have table
header elements and we're going to have
to have
uh five for the time destination flight
gate and remarks but then also one spare
one because I want to put in like a
little icon on the left
so of a little airplane so we're gonna
have to leave space for that so let's
make five sorry six in total that is
one two three four five six so the first
one is going to be blank this one is
going to be time this one is going to be
destination flight
and then we have the gates and then we
also have the remarks okay
so there we go and perhaps let's give
these an ID so we can pick them out
later in our styling okay oops that you
should be ID
time this one is ID
destination
this one's gonna be ID of
flight
and then of course we have the well you
guessed it gauge and the remarks for
saying like if it's delayed or canceled
and and so on so that's our header and
like we said we're going to inject stuff
into the body using JavaScript so we
could just pick out the t-body tag or
you know you really should pick it up by
the ID so I'm going to give this the ID
of table body
wonderful and then also let's give this
a header so we're going to use the H1
tag for this and let's put departures so
heading sorry I've got a heading
there we go so at the moment if we open
this up so I can use this shortcut right
here to open it up for me thank you so
much webstorm that's what you'll see and
if we inspect the page
get about console logs
and if we inspect the page
maybe just make this
smaller
you will see that in the body we have a
div we made with the classic departures
you've got H1 element and then we've got
a table with the table head and the
table body so basically everything we've
just added great now before we get to
the JavaScript just going to start this
up do some very basic styling so that we
have a little bit uh more of a visual to
work with essentially
so let's carry on so if you do know how
to open that and you're using vs code
perhaps all you'd have to do is right
click on here copy the path
so the absolute path and then in here
you just paste that okay so I could do
that in word sum too
great
so now let's do some styling right let's
do it here's my style sheet
and the first thing that I'm going to do
is just say that everything I'm going to
give this the font family
of uh Ubuntu which we're gonna have to
get from the Google fonts
uh webpage Ubuntu something that's a
little bit bigger
condensed and then as a backup let's
just have Suns serif why not so now if I
go to
Google fonts
to search for Ubuntu
condense that's the one we want let's go
ahead and add it so I'm gonna actually
just pick
how many of these
okay let's put the 400
oh there's only 400. great so we can do
it two ways we can put it in our HTML
but I'm going to choose to put it
in our CSS using this so using import so
just go ahead and copy that
and then back in webstorm
just gonna paste it in like so I'm just
going to minimize this you can see a
little better
great
so this is looking good and if I now
open this up
in here and refresh that font will be
applied
so now let's well let's carry on styling
so what else I'm gonna do so we want
every the font to be applied to
everything and the dock and we want the
font to be white so I can just write
white or let's make it like an off-white
because white is a bit too jarring for
me
and let's make the font
size
35 pixels okay so that's going to be
applies everything now and now in the
body
well the body I just want to Center the
actual div with the closet display so
I'm going to give the whole body display
Flex justify content
Center
so that will Center it uh in the middle
of the page but you also want to center
it from the top to bottom so to do this
I'm actually gonna have to assign a
height otherwise that will not work I'm
just going to give it the uh height of
my viewport and then we use align items
Center okay so without giving it a
height this would not work and this
would not work and this would not work
without a display Flex got it good so
you need all for to Center something in
the pitch
and now let's also give this a
background color
I'm going to go with RGB this is a color
that I picked out previously from the
previous tutorial where we just did this
in JavaScript with no API
great so now if we once again just have
a look
and refresh the page amazing so you will
now see that this the departures
the div with the class departures it's
centered in the page and the styling's
been applied as well
great so let's carry on so we've done
the body now let's actually also just
give some padding to the H1 element so
I'm just going to do padding 10.
pixels just like so and let's grab the
div with the class of departures so dot
is for class name and I'm just going to
give it a background color that's a bit
darker right because we're essentially
trying to create something that looks
like a board visually so that's what I'm
doing and then it's just round off the
corners using border radius I'm going to
use 10 pixels for that and also give it
a padding to space everything out from
the everything that we're going to be
putting inside of this of this
great so there we go and now if I want
to say that the table that lives inside
the departures the devil class
departures I mean it's unlikely we're
going to put another table in on the uh
document but you know just if if you
didn't know how to do that I'm picking
out the element of table that lives
inside the element with the classes
departures okay and only this site and
this side will only be applied to that
element that lives inside the div with
the class of departures
so
let's give this a background color of a
little bit lighter now I'm going to go
46 46
46.
and let's make sure that all the text is
aligned left because at the moment it's
centered so if we have a look at what
this looks like now
there we go
so our departures do our div of the
class of Departures this color and then
our table
is this kind of lighter gray
cool let's
carry on
what else do we need to style well I'm
actually going to
say actually this should be fine for now
let's carry on so in my app now I said
that I want to start injecting stuff
into my uh my my table essentially from
JavaScript so that's what I'm gonna do
so once again we're going to use this
API so again these are example responses
we're going to get the destination the
status the departing time the gate I'm
essentially going to feed it into here
okay as table rows okay I'm also going
to make them do this cool flipping
animation if you saw my previous video
on this where we make this in pure
JavaScript
so let's do it to do this fast I'm just
going to build a mini backend
so in my file structure you'll see I
just have three files however I think it
might be nice to now put these three
files in a folder called client so we
can separate out from the back end I'm
just going to drag these three in here
like so
so they are all now in the folder called
client and we're going to make another
folder
or we don't have to you can make another
folder for the server but as we're just
having one file I'm not going to I'm
just going to call the file server.js
okay so that shouldn't be in here that
should be on the same level as
the folder client
so there we go server client and it
lives in the flight widget live project
great
so here is where we're going to be
writing our backend however
we need to do a few things
you need to have node installed okay
because we're going to have to use node
and we're also going to have to use npm
so if you haven't please go ahead and
visit here
so install node
and just select which one you need for
me it will be the Mac OS installer so
you're going to have to do that and then
also we're going to have to install npm
so that we can use it and store packages
okay
so here we go npmg install npm this is
for installing it globally
okay so just go ahead and do that I'm
going to show you how
so you just do that I mean that's it or
if you're using uh vs code you might
want to get your terminal up your
terminal looks like
this
okay and it doesn't matter where you do
it because it's Global so just go ahead
and do that
great
now that we've done that once again I'm
just going to show you how to do this uh
in your terminals
so you would go into wherever you stored
this project so for me it's with some
projects and then I go into flight
widget
live
and then you're gonna have to do npm in
it okay so run that I'm not going to do
it here I'm actually going to do it in
here so I would just do npm in it making
sure that I'm in the flight widget live
and hit enter
and then I'm just going to go through
these and hit enter okay the package
name correct version one correct
description I'm going to need blank
entry point blank or savage.js sorry it
says come on blank everything is just
the default and then is this okay yes
and that will generate a package Json
file for me you're gonna watch it happen
I'm gonna wait for that to happen
and there we go
so you'll see this file show up and this
is what's in it we're gonna have to add
some packages in here as well as well as
a script to start our back end but first
off let's go ahead and install the
packages that we need they're Express
that will help us get uh roots
uh with our routing so to get
uh certain things as well as listen out
to the port we're also going to need
axios in order to make the requests
we're going to need cores we're going to
need dot EnV in order to hide our uh
rapid API Keys safely so we don't upload
it onto GitHub or anything like that and
we're also going to need nodemon to
listen out to changes on the backend so
please go ahead and install that using
npmi or npm install and hit enter
okay
and that should populate in here with
the versions that we're using for this
tutorial so if you're watching this in
the future something doesn't work it
could be down to the version you are
using so just remember
that okay so there we are that's when
populated with the versions you know you
can just change these if you need to and
then just run npmi again after saving
that file but of course I'm not going to
do that because this is the versions I'm
using and 0.6 probably doesn't exist yet
right
cool so those are the packages now let's
write the code for our server
so the first thing that we're going to
actually need to get is the packages but
first off no sorry we need to define the
port so I'm going to define the port as
running on Port 8000 on my local
computer
now let's start off actually with
getting the
code that we need right so this is the
code we need in order to get this
response so again I'm literally just
going to copy all of this
I'm going to take it looks super easy
I'm just going to paste it in here okay
so that is the code that we are going to
need in order to get the flight data
from Pearson's Airport
so we're gonna have to wrap this in a uh
get root
so to do that let's use express or const
Express equals require the package
express
okay and once we have that we actually
need to call the Express to release all
of its wonderfulness and save it
something else I'm going to choose to
save it as app so we can actually use it
uh an app use will also allow us if I do
app use allow us to use course or not
block by course we're going to call
cores but of course we also need to
install cause so require
s
if you don't know much about cores I do
go into it in a few tutorials so I'm not
going to go into it now but just know
that if you get a message saying block I
call us it's probably because you
haven't done this
and then of course we need the
dot in V package in order to hide our
rapid API key
great
I think that's it uh axios course we'll
just I'm just going to move this up here
actually
and add default
great so
yeah wonderful let's carry on now just
to check everything's running I'm going
to do app Listen to listen out for
changes on to listen out to the port
so I'm just going to pass through the
port number and then write console log
running on
port
and then the port number
okay
I'm actually going to put that at the
bottom
and now
we're going to wrap this in an app get
so this is something this is Express
routing and if we visit localhost 8000
forward slash flight so we're defining
this ourselves we could have just left
it as you know localhost 8000 if we
wanted to but I think it's more readable
to give it an actual path and then we
get the request and response
and then I'm literally is going to take
all of this all of that code that we
copied from Rapid API and just put in
here
okay so that is what it looks like
now let's also make a DOT EnV file on
the same level as the server so just in
the root of my project a file dot EnV so
that we can hide
our rapid API keys I'm just going to go
ahead and Define it here rapid API
key
and then I'm just going to grab this
paste in here we don't need to say it's
a string that's kind of implied and now
that means I can use process e and V and
go into the EnV file so and then get the
rapid API key okay so I'm just going
into that file
great
so we're console logging the response
data we also want to actually show it in
the browser so to do this I'm going to
do res Json and just pass through the
response data as well
wonderful
now let's write a script so we can run
this right so I'm going to say that if
we write npm run
start oh
I feel like that's already been added
for us
did we do that I don't think so so
that's quite cool however I'm going to
do node and one so it continuously
listens out to changes okay so note of
on node will just listen out once
because no demand will continuously
listen after changes on the server.js
file
great
so now like I said if I run npm run
start
this should it's running on Port 8000
this also means that if I now visit
localhost 8000 forward slash flights
you will see all the Destiny or the
departure flights for Pearson Airport
and there's a lot so this is looking
cool I'm just gonna say I want the first
six however and we could do this on the
server and it's probably better to do on
the server right so
I'm just going to dot slice the first
I think that's fine
great so that's our super simple
backhand look we can even like just put
it all in might even all fit
nearly it nearly all fits uh that's our
super simple back end okay now we need
to get this data and bring it to the
front end so I'm going to show you how
to do that
so
back to here
now
the first thing I'm going to do is just
pick out this element by the ID so we
can start injecting the flights into it
so I'm going to Define it as table
body
and I'm going to use document get
elements not animations get element by
Adi table body
and now I'm actually going to write
let's just do it in a function because I
think it makes it more readable
um
you can write function I'm going to use
a function expression though
so there's my get flight and I'm going
to use fetch to fetch literally this
URLs of course our backend needs to be
running for this to work we're going to
get this
and we're just going to fetch all of
that Json
so this means we need to do some
chaining right so once we once that
promise returns then we're going to get
the response
response from response Jason
and then whatever comes back as the Json
we're going to save this as I'm going to
save as flights I'm choosing to call it
flights and I'm actually going to for
now just console log flights so we can
see what's going on but we're going to
pass this into a function right because
we need these to resolve before this
happens hence I'm going to pass it into
a function but I'll show you that later
on and then we're going to catch any
errors so catch
error
console log
cool so now if I of course call this
and then we go in here
to our flight widget refresh
and we move this didn't we we move this
into
client
there we go so if I look in the console
log now
we have to wait a bit ta-da okay so that
took a while and that could be
problematic so this is again I'll show
you this later but it's problematic but
we'll get over this right I'm going to
show you how to uh essentially make
stuff happen once this is resolved and
once we get the data back so this is
what we are working with okay of course
the object doesn't really come back
in the exact same shape as we would
ideally like like we did for the plain
JavaScript tutorial where we made our
own object but don't worry we can use
this data to create our own objects too
in the format that we want but
essentially we've got all the
information here so this is looking
great
so what I'm going to do now is get all
of this data and pass it into a function
to populate the table
okay because once again if we just for
example if I just wrote a function here
populate table then we wouldn't have the
data and it would read the function
populate table without the data okay and
then nothing would work
so
again I'm just going to write if I um
function expression for this you can
just write function if you wish but this
is what I have chosen to do so here we
go here's my function populate table
and what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to pass through the flights into
it which means that here once this is
all this is resolved then I want to pass
flights into populate table and call
this function
okay so let's get rid of this console
log
cool
and what do I want to happen well for
each flight so for each flight I'm gonna
say that each object I just named flight
of flights
so once again I'm just going to show you
because we have an array right it's an
array of objects so I've essentially
called each object a flight now so each
object so the the whole array is flights
each object is called flight
so for each object in the array
essentially this is saying
what do I want to do well I want to
create a document create element and I
want to create a table row
so let's save this as table right
and what else do I want to do I actually
want to create a table icon too so as I
said I want a little icon of a um
airplane
so create element and I'm just going to
create I don't want table data because
each row takes table datas yeah okay so
once again
just going to show you
here's our table here's a table head
we're going to create a table row
and then we're going to create table
data here is called th but for the body
we're going to use TG so we're going to
have to create one two three four five
six
table datas
cool
so I'm going to create a table icon for
the first one uh and so table icon
text content I'm going to give it this
like I said the airplane
just like that
and now we're going to essentially get
the table icon and put it in the rows
we're going to get the table row and use
append
table icon okay so we'll put the icon in
the table row and now we also need to
put the table Row in the table body so
table body append
table row
so let's refresh that
and wait for it to resolve
so there's our first uh row column sorry
and we've put in a little airplane in it
yay
cool
however I don't know why there's only
one
there should have been
a lot more
let's check it out
so I'm just going to console
log
flights here to see what's going on
okay
so yes we are getting
six items
put only one table row is being created
why is that
it's because we didn't put this
I need to wrap that
or in here it needs to be in the loop so
now
there should be
more of the little icons there we go so
we get six icons now okay because We're
looping over for every flight or every
item that exists in our array
great
so now that's working let's continue so
now for each flight so for each I guess
um
object
before we put this all in the table row
so up here I'm going to redefine my
object so I'm going to redefine the
flight details so I'm literally going to
make an object that is going to take the
time
a destination
the flight
the gate
and then the remarks
okay so essentially we're just kind of
trying to get something for these five
columns okay and from our data where we
can see
that we can get the flight
departing
so the we've called it flight so the
object's departing let's use that
would probably also slice it down right
just so you get the first five
characters and then the destination
that's just destination the flight is
the flight number and the gate is gate
and remarks's Status so let's see if we
can remember that
flight departing again because we've
called this object flight up here
flight
oh my gosh what was this flight details
it's like number wasn't it flight number
this was flight gate
and this was flight status
and then we said we wanted to party and
we wanted to just want to get the first
five characters
so there we go
and let's make this to uppercase
and this also to
uppercases or capital and this was in an
array so I'm guessing there's going to
be more than one but we just want one so
I'm just going to return the first value
from that erasing the shift method
cool and now
so we've redefined our new object let's
now use that object to essentially
create a table data cell for each of the
items so I'm going to do so again so
const I'm going to call it flight detail
so each flight detail that exists in
this object in the flight details object
and for each item that exists I'm going
to create a table data cell so document
create element
TD
I'm going to save this as table cell
and now I'm going to essentially so
whatever these words are I don't really
want I want them because I want each
little each word to be separated our
owner create an array from it so that we
can create little flipping boards I'm
going to get the word
and create an array from it like I said
so array from
and then we're going to look in the
flight details
object and look for something by the
flight detail
okay so essentially I'm just creating
little arrays so that we can now create
little cards for them
so const
um
we're gonna have to have the index this
time so index and then the letter
for each of the cards of the word
entries
okay
uh so great so now that we've got each
word split out into an array so we can
create Little Boxes for them I'm going
to create a box for them so document
create element
active
and let's call this a letter element
great
so of course now we have that we need to
put that letter element
into
the table
cell so let's get the table cell and
append
the letter element and we also need to
so after still in this for Loop we also
need to grab the table row and append
the
table so
okay so of course we won't really be
able to see The Styling on this now but
I'm just going to show you what this
looks like I'm trying not to make as
many cores because it's obviously taking
time to make the call and we don't want
to go over the certain amount either
so
hmm
we've created the table data and for
each letter we've created a div
so that's looking good we just need to
actually put the letter in so let's
actually get the letter element
and use text content to add the
letter okay so for each word entry I'm
just gonna
do
that
great and maybe let's style up the div a
little bit so in here
in the departures
table
any div that lives inside of it I'm
going to give it a border
that is solid
4 pixels RGB
okay so I'm just making little cards
and let's also give it a background
color
of black but let's make it RGB
to rgb000
and then Min width of the card is going
to be 20 pixels and the height is going
to be 40 pixels and I'm going to make
everything float left
okay so once again let's check it out
fresh
and let's wait the apis do the same
recording the API
so there we
I go this is looking good as you can see
what we have done is go each word we
spit out onto an array within each item
in the array we made each letter go into
a little card that we created or a div
to be precise
so this is looking cool the last thing
I'm going to do is just add a flip thing
so that we get it everything flips over
so let's go ahead and
do that
so to do this I'm actually going to put
adding the letter in a set timeout so
set
timeout and then just put in a callback
function
and then this set timeout this is why I
need the index because if I did 100 then
all the letters would flip after 100
milliseconds but if I'm in multiply this
by an index the first one will flip over
at zero the second one will flip over
100 milliseconds the third one will flip
over 300 milliseconds and so on so that
is how you would do it and then I just
want to show the letter okay so it's
going to be like one after the other I'm
also actually going to get the letter
element
and assign it a class which we're going
to make
so class list add this is how you add a
class using JavaScript and that class is
going to be called flip
and actually also
yeah I actually want to let's put in
that letter element in here too so it
actually gets put in at the same time I
think that would work
better
cool
so now in here let's write the flip
class
so I'm just going to do
T flip and when the div is applied this
class I'm going to animate it so I'm
going to use animation uh 0.5 seconds
linear
and then we're gonna have to write the
animation which I've called flipping so
keyframes
flippings what we called it
and
I'm just going to transform
it to rotate X
zero degrees
and then I'm actually just going to copy
this because we're just going to change
a few things
so then at 50 it's going to rotate X 90
and then
back to zero at 100.
great
so I'm pretty sure that's it
is it not liking that
oh well okay
so now let's check it out
we should probably hard code this table
a little bit as well so that doesn't
look like this any point in time and
ta-da that is looking so cool
so yes let's do a few final
styling things and that is just gonna
hard code
some of these elements
I'm going to say that the
div with the ID of time or sorry the
element
I'm going to say that the element with
the easy of time so whatever holds our
headings always going to have a width of
160 pixels
then the element with the ID of
destination is going to have a width of
700 pixels
and flight is going to have
205 pixels
gate is going to have a width of
135 pixels
and finally
remarks
it's gonna have a width of 260 pixels
okay so now the width will not change
it looked like this one is empty and
then
whoosh
so that is looking
cool
you can of course hard code the height
as well that part is totally up to you
great so thanks very much I hope you've
enjoyed this lesson and how to take a
simple JavaScript project and populate
it using an API
thanks so much for watching and I'll see
you again soon
so let's do it let's get up our code
editors so I am using webstorm so I'm
just going to spin up a react up fast by
clicking on react right here and then
this means I can just call this whatever
I want I'm going to call this reacts
flight with jet just like so and it's
going to use the command npx create
react app to spin up a react app for me
along with all of its boilerplate code
so I'm just going to go ahead and click
create and let that do its thing
okay
so that's going to spin up all the
files and directories for me if you're
not using webstorm and you'd like to
just use the terminal to do this just go
ahead and select a directory of your
choice so for example I could use
development and then I'd use the command
npx create react app and then I call the
project whatever I wish but as you know
I'm not doing this way I'm using
webstorm which is kind of doing all of
that for me okay so we're just going to
wait until all the files and directories
get populated in my project at the
moment there is a package Json and
that's it there's going to be a lot more
so while that's doing its thing let's
head over to data Stacks which is going
to be the database management system I
am using for this project I'm using it
because it's free and I use it in most
of my projects so I'm pretty used to it
so I'm just going to go ahead and sign
in go ahead and sign up if you haven't
already and once you have signed up
you'll be taken to the data Stacks Astra
dashboard just like so
and as you can see here I have many
databases already I'm going to go ahead
and create a new one so I'm going to go
ahead and click here and that will take
me to this dashboard where I'm going to
call my data boost something well I'm
just going to call it let's call this
the flight widget
projects and the key space name for this
I'm going to choose to call this flights
just like so
okay
great
so that is what I've chosen to call my
key space next I'm going to choose a
region I'm going to choose the closest
one to me which at the moment I forgot
where I am I'm in London so I'm going to
go ahead and choose Europe West Europe
and create a database okay
great and now while our app is spinning
up this should be created it will show
you the token and secret client please
go ahead and save that I'm going to show
you mine because I'm going to be
deleting this anyway by the time this
tutorial comes out so this is what you
should look like just copy that and keep
it somewhere safe
okay so go ahead and save it somewhere
I'm going to save mine on notes
and wonderful so now we can go to the
database that data will be needed to
communicate with your database later on
so now that we are here we can see our
key space called Flights but we have to
wait as our status is initializing so we
can't use this quite yet so while that's
doing its thing let's go and check on
our project
so back in here you will see that in my
directory called reaction like widget we
will see all these files and directories
okay so that's been generated for us
let's just get rid of that for now I'm
actually going to get rid of a lot of
these as we don't need them
so I'm going to delete these three okay
I'm just going to really scale it back
delete these three files delete anyway
and then I'm going to delete the test
file as we're not going to be doing any
tests in this project and then the
delete the app CSS file was as we're
just going to be storing all our CSS in
one place okay which means that now in
the nxjs file I can get rid of this as
we're not reporting with vitals
so get rid of the input for it let's
just make this a little bit bigger
and then we can keep all of these I'm
just going to get rid of these
semicolons and great so that is what
your index.js file should look like and
a stripped down version
next let's have a look at the app.js
file so once again let's just change a
few things I'm not going to be using
semicolons and I'm just going to get rid
of all of this okay all of this in the
return so we can start fresh and I'm
going to change this to a function
expression just because I prefer working
with
them
great and for now I'm just going to
return
an empty element we don't need to import
the app CSS file as I said we will be
doing all our CSS in one file so that is
the content of my app.js file that is
the content of my index.js file and this
is the content of my index CSS file
which again I'm just going to delete so
we can start fresh
great everything else just leave as it
is
so now that we have done that the first
thing I'm actually going to do is just
create a server so at the moment this is
all in my directory called react flight
widget and we have the source directory
right here I'm just going to make a new
file in the root of my project
so new
files it's going to be a JavaScript file
go to server Js
and here's essentially where all my
backend code is going to go okay so just
one file I call it server just to make
it really clear that this is our backend
and all of this is going to be our front
end okay so everything in here and
they're going to share a package Json
file
great
so what are we going to do here well we
are going to have to communicate with
our database in this file so to do this
I'm going to have to define a port I'm
going to say I want it to run on Port
8000 we're also going to have to get
axios so const axios equals require the
package axios okay so that is something
that I'm going to have to install we're
also going to get the package express
so require
Express
and the package cores so that we can get
rid of those Pax key cause messages
which I will show you and then we're
going to also need the dot EnV
package
so that we can read
information from a DOT DNB file in which
we're going to store our API key
so I hope you already know what all
these packages are as I'm not going to
go too much into them the axios package
is essentially going to help us make get
requests because we're going to get the
data from our database and express is
what's going to help us do the routing
okay
cause as I said is going to help us when
we see the pesky cause message which I
will show you later and the dot EMV file
as I said is going to help us get
information from the dot EMV file that
we will create to store API key so let's
go ahead and install all of these so
just make sure that you're in the right
directory which I am and I'm going to
use the command npmi for install to
install the axios package the Express
package the course package and the dot
EnV package just like so I'm also going
to install the nodeive on which will
help us listen out to constant changes
on the server.js file so just go ahead
and install this so hit enter and let
that do its thing
okay and great so now if we look in the
package.json file you will see those
packages right here
okay so there we go if you are doing
this in the future and something doesn't
work it could be down to the package you
are using so just make sure to change
the package and then run npmi to
reinstall all those packages again after
you save the file however we're not
going to do that now so let's just put
it back to the packages that we
installed so these are the latest ones
right now in time
okay so let's carry on
it's going to zoom in a little bit for
you to see now we're going to also have
to add another script because at the
moment we have a script to start you
know the just the reacts app I'm going
to write another script which I'm going
to call
start back end so that's how we're going
to call this script so sort of back end
and I'm going to change this to front
and actually
and here I'm going to listen out to
changes on the server JS file and to
listen up constantly the changes I'm
going to use node in one which I just
installed okay so that will listen out
to constant changes on my server.js file
great so I'm not going to run this yet
let's just get rid of that for now let's
carry on writing our code for here
so first off I'm going to actually get
everything that Express comes with and
release all of its magic wonderfulness
and to do this well I've stored it under
the cons Express which means if I grab
Express now and call it all of that will
be released so everything that comes
with the Express package so to use that
I'm actually going to save it as another
const called app which means that now I
can use app and use any methods that
come with Express and one of those is
listen and that's going to help us
listen out to the port okay and it's
going to listen up to the port and it's
going to consult log out
running on ports and then we're just
going to
grab the port name okay so that now if I
do
npm Run start
back and and hit enter
you will see running on Port 8000 you
know I make any changes here and save
obviously that won't work because that
has um that's not code it's common that
out it will rerun
okay so that's constantly listening out
for changes
great
now let's check what our database is
doing so as you will see here it is it
is online this is great so this is
looking good
we can now use it so what I'm going to
do is add data into this manually and
that's going to be our flight widget
data so we're pretending we're an
airline essentially okay I'll come in
here's my Airline data of course
realistically the database would hold
data that someone is constantly updating
but we're just going to put it in once
and leave it okay because it's for the
project but you should know how to do
this so I'm going to show you how
so
here is our database I'm going to
connect and there's many ways you can
connect however this time I'm just going
to use the document API and I'm going to
use the Swagger UI documents to help me
visualize this okay so all I've done is
click on here and let's launch the
Swagger UI
now we've created a key space now first
off with key spaces we need to create a
collection that will hold all our data
so let's go ahead and do that I'm going
to create a new collection in a keyspace
name and try it out
now this has been Auto populated for us
so thanks very much data stacks and the
key space otherwise known as Name ID in
here as we know is called flight as
that's what we called it and the
collection that we're going to create
you can call it whatever we wish I'm
going to choose to call it
departures okay so that's going to be
our flights departures so my collection
is called departures and now if I
execute this
you will see that that has worked we get
a 201 response so great that's looking
good we've made a collection now let's
put stuff into our collection so what
I'm going to do is create a new document
this time and try this out the keyspace
name otherwise known as the name ID in
here the name space ID is called Flights
and the collection is called departures
as we just made it and in here well I'm
going to go ahead and just create an
object that's going to represent one
departure now I've already pre-made this
for us so we don't have to sit here all
day writing them out so this is what my
object is going to look like okay as you
can see here we have the stasis
I'm delayed for this flight the
destination is Halifax Canada the flight
number is
y9521 and it's departing at 4 P.M and
we've also got the gate number okay so
there we go that's what one object is
going to look like and now if I execute
this
ta-da we got a 2-1 response that object
essentially has been put into my
departures collection and that is its
document ID if we ever need to pick it
up by document 18. I'm just going to go
ahead and put in some more okay so once
again I have pre-made these just to make
our lives a little bit easier so there's
another
flight I'm just going to execute that
and let that do its thing and that has
been put in because we can see the
document ID in the response body let's
put in another one
okay so this flight is on time because
the other two have been delayed I'm just
going to put in a few more to check that
one has worked and it has
this is a canceled flight to Oman I'm
going to execute that and then we have
one more and it's to crack off Poland
Okay so there we go great and we're just
going to execute that and wonderful so
now if we search all the documents in a
collection let's try this out the key
space name is flights otherwise known as
the namespace name and Swagger The
Collection is called departures and I'm
just going to get back everything okay
we could limit how many items we want to
get back but I don't want to do that I
just want everything and wonderful
so there we go okay at the moment it's
just returning three however if I view
this so if I actually
get this URL okay this one right here
that's essentially what we created by
entering all these details that is the
URL and this is what we're also going to
have to pass through with that accept
application Json and the Cassandra token
so that's what essentially what we're
going to recreate in our back end so
let's get up our web store
now I'm going to use app again which
holds all of our Express wonderfulness
and I'm going to use the get method
let's move this a little bit bigger and
we don't need that and what I'm going to
do is get and I'm going to define a root
I'm going to say that if we visit
localhost 8004 slash flights then we
want to essentially see the data from
our database so this is the Syntax for
doing a get request in Express and then
I'm going to have to essentially get
pass through some options okay so the
options are what we saw the method is
going to be get even though I don't
think we need to specify that if we're
doing it up here so let's not worry
about that the URL for this
is going to be the URL that I stole from
Swagger which we can hide as well but
I'm just going to keep it like this for
now
and then the headers well the headers
are gonna be
these two
Okay so we've got accept application
Json
and then we're also going to have
let's make it like this
X
Cassandra
token you can sort of spelled it exactly
the same way
as it's spelled here and we're going to
use our own token that we saved
so there we go that's my one that we saw
earlier
and now under the headers and under the
option so that's our options all of that
I'm going to use axios which is the
package that we installed up here to
request
options
then
get the response
and once we get that response Well for
now I'm just going to consort log the
response
data
but we also want to see in the browser
and for that I need to use res Json and
pass through the response data like so
and then of course we're going to catch
any errors so catch
error
just like so I'm just going to console
log the error
okay
great
so
I think that should be it that is a
whole piece of code
so now
if we look and localhost 8000 forward
slash flights
we get that data showing up so we can
use it now if we wanted to limit or say
that you know we want to get all six
then I can actually say that I want six
I can really hard code it to only get
six backs I'm going to do page size six
and then you'll see all six of those
flights so let's go ahead and add that
to the URL
right
here
okay
great now at this point I'm actually
going to create a DOT dnv file so new
file dot EnV so we can store all of this
as this is kind of sensitive even the
URL is sensitive right
so I'm going to essentially get this
whole URL all of it including the page
size or we can actually leave the page
size maybe let's leave it let's just get
this URL and save it here and I'm going
to say this is URL just like so okay we
don't need to put strings as it's
implied that it's a string then save
this and I'm also going to
get the token
and save this token right here so that
it's hidden from when we push this up to
GitHub and so on so let's get all of
that
and paste it in here like so okay so
there's my URL it ends in forward slash
departures and there's my Cassandra took
great so now to access these we can
simply just use process EnV and then
token okay process in V is essentially a
way for us to access anything in the dot
DMV file and token is what we called our
token and we can do the same for the URL
here in fact I'm going to use back text
because I'm going to pass
the URL in like this so process e and V
URL and then I'm going to also attach
this string at the end just so it's
visible to whoever's looking at this in
case they're wondering why all their
details are coming back is because we
capped it at six
great
so amazing we've essentially finished
our back end how painless was that
so now that we have that let's get to
using all of this data that we have here
by building out a front end
so let's do it
so to do this I'm going to actually get
out my terminal again and create a new
tab and run the command npm Run start
front end this time making sure to spell
it correctly and making sure that you're
in the correct directory and hit enter
so that will spin up our front end
okay right here should have nothing in
it because I deleted everything in it so
it should just be a blank page okay and
it is
great
so that is working well I think we are
done with the day space for now so I'm
just going to
get rid of that and great
now the first thing we want to do I'm
actually going to get rid of the seven
two uh and let's just go up let's have a
think about the components that are
going to make up this app well we're of
course going to have a table we're also
going to have the table body as well as
the table header and the table body is
going to hold all our flight details and
the table header is going to hold
information about the column names
we're also going to have table rows that
make up our table body okay as they can
easily be components as they are
reusable as well as table cells which
will make up each cell that holds the
names of things in our table okay so
let's go ahead and start doing that now
so
all I'm going to do is create a new
directory called components this time
components and in here I'm actually
going to use this as a template I'm
going to create a new file it's going to
be a Javascript file and it's going to
be for our table and I'm going to store
this as a table jsx file okay and then
just paste it like so and I'm just going
to change this to the table export
default table
great
in fact we should probably change this
to a jsx file as well as it includes jsx
so let's just go ahead and rename this
app jsx
and this one as well rename index.jsx
great
so we've got our table next we're going
to have a table body so new
file table OD Dot jsx
and then I'm just going to add body here
and here
Okay so we've got table body now we're
also going to have table head so new
file table head Dot jsx
add that file
table head and table head
now we're also going to have a table row
right so new file table row Dot jsx
let's put don't ask again
and then this is going to be change to
table row I'm not forgetting to changing
but here at the bottom two and one more
and that's going to be a table cell so
table cell Dot jsx
and change this to table cell and change
this to table cell 2.
great
so let's just get rid of these
at the moment
okay
so what I know is that I'm going to have
a div here and this div I essentially
want to
hold all of my departures information
together which means I want to put in
the table along with a header that says
departures okay so I'm going to put in a
header element and it's just going to
say it departures like so perhaps let's
make a capital to make it consistent
with the previous ones that I made and
I'm also going to use the table
component now okay that I have made so
just like that which means you need to
import it in here so import table from
and then I'm going to go into the
components and I'm going to grab the
table
component just like so so at the moment
this won't really do much okay I'm gonna
actually start this up I'm going to give
this the class name of Departures just
so we can Center the departures header
and the table okay so
let's go ahead and do that I'm going to
grab this and then the dot CSS file I'm
going to grab the class of departures so
dot for class name
and I'm just going to give this a
background color so we can see a little
bit of what's going on and I'm just
going to make it this dark gray I'm
going to give it a border radius to
soften it up of 10 pixels and I'm also
going to give it some padding space it
out from the header and the table and
then I'm also going to give it a box
Shadow which I've pre-made before so
it's going to have
this dark
gray color with a 0.25 Alpha for opacity
and I want it to be zero on the x-axis
13 pixels on the y-axis 27 pixels blur
and 5 pixels spread okay and then I'm
going to Overlay with another one whoops
there we go
and that's rgba
this time is black with 0.3 opacity I'm
just going to put this on another line
maybe and zero pixels x-axis 8 pixels
y-axis 16 pixels and minus eight pixels
spread
great we don't need the p x and the zero
as it's redundant
so we've done that and now if we look in
the browser
oops maybe we should have just kept that
as it is
unless we can change something in the
package Json maybe that's I think we're
just over complicating it
maybe let's try it really around this so
npm Run start front end
and there we go okay so that's fine we
just had to rerun it as we renamed this
file to a jsx file
okay
so now you will see the div with the
class name of Departures if I inspect
this
you will see that
in the
root okay so there we go there's a
different class departures and in its
got a header which says departures and
it should have the table component but
at the moment that's returning nothing
so that's all we'll see let's go ahead
and change the font as well so actually
what I'm also going to do is say that
also all the fonts that I'm going to use
are going to have the color of an
off-white so RGB
240 240 240 just like so
I'm going to use the font family of
Ubuntu condensed which I'm actually
going to get from Google
fonts API so condensed
and then as a backup we're going to have
Suns
serif
and
Ariel
okay
great
I'm also going to make the font size for
everything 35 pixels so now if we look
in here there we go we get the
departures let's go ahead and also get
the Google font API so we can install
Ubuntu
so here we go fonts Ubuntu
and we're just going to select the
regular one
and then we're just going to import it
so I'm just going to grab this like so
and paste it in okay so there we go
we've just imported the Ubuntu condense
and we can now use it in the font family
so great there we go you will see that
font has changed wonderful
let's carry on
so now that we have that I'm also going
to Center
the departures so what I'm going to do
is grab the whole body of my document
and use display
Flex on it and first of all I'm going to
Center everything horizontally
and then I'm going to give the body a
height of 100 viewport height which will
be in the I can now align items on the
adjacent accent to this so essentially
vertically and I'm going to assign them
Center
let's also give the body a background
color I'm going to choose to give it to
this orangey like color just like so
okay so there we go we have centered
you did with a class of departures
great now let's go ahead and work on the
table element so I'm going to go ahead
and get it up here
now the table element isn't really going
to have much in it it's just going to
say that I want this to be a table right
so I've got the table element and then
we're going to have to have a table of
head right but I'm going to choose to
put this in its own component so there
we go we've already made the table head
component here and we also need the
table body because as we said we want
the table body to hold all of our data
about the flights so let's go ahead and
import those two components that we made
so import table head from table head and
also import table body from table body
great and once again that's all we're
going to do on the table let's work on
the table head first
so what do I want the table head to
return well I'm going to use the table
heads
element
and it's closing tag
to create a table head and inside of
here I'm going to have to create a table
row
so there's our table row
note that it's separate to the table row
we have here because this one's
specifically for the body the table head
is going to have a table row which is
going to contain a table header
with the first one being empty and the
second one
is going to be a column title of time
the next one we're going to have
destination so it's going to be the
column head of our destination column
destination
next we're going to have a column ahead
for our flights
then we're gonna have one for the gates
and then finally we're going to happen
for remarks okay and marks
and I'm going to actually pick each one
of these out by its ID because I'm going
to give it a custom sizing so that one's
going to be time this one I'm going to
give it the ID of destination oh no
no
yes
destination
let's give this one the ID of well you
guessed it light this one the ID of
eight
and this one the ID of
remarks okay
so at the moment this will just like
this but as I said I want to space them
all out a little bit so perhaps let's go
ahead and do that now
so first off maybe let's also just give
this some padding so let's pick out the
header I'm just going to go ahead and do
that pick up the header and give it a
padding of 10 pixels just to space it
out from everything else and now in the
departures
the table itself that we created I want
that to be a different background color
actually I want to be this lighter gray
that I picked out earlier
and I want all the text to align to the
left
so let's have a look at what that looks
like at the moment
there we go you will see this is my
table okay you will see it's got a
lighter gray background
now let's actually get to picking out
all of the
column name so we're going to get the
flight and I'm going to hard coat the
width of this column to be 160 pixels
next we're going to get the destination
and I'm also going to hard code this to
have a width of 700 pixels this time
then we're going to get the time in fact
this one the first one's time isn't it
the second one is flight
and this is going to have a width of 205
pixels
then we have the gate this is going to
be a short one
so grab the gate ID and then just give
it a width
of 135 pixels
and then remarks
it's going to have a width of 260.
fixes
okay
so that should have spaced them all out
a little bit
great
so I believe we are done with the table
header let's move on to the table body
next and populating it with our data so
let's go back to here I'm going to get
rid of this we're done with this for now
and let's get the table body
so the table body well we already know
that this should return the T body
element because that is how we make
tables
so
tea body and what we're going to have to
do is map stuff onto table rows so this
is the ideal place for us to essentially
get the data from our backend so that's
what we're going to do and for this
we're going to have to import
use State and use effect from react
okay because we're going to essentially
get the data so let's actually write a
function for this called get flights
just like so
and I'm going to use fetch from
JavaScript in order to fetch data from
here so I'm just going to grab this URL
it really is that simple and I'm going
to paste it like so and then I'm going
to do some chaining so once we get the
response
response I want to get it's Json
then
I'm gonna get the let's call it flight
slot data flights and I'm going to set
flights so let's go ahead and use const
light set flights
use state
and start off with the state game no so
what this essentially is if you haven't
really come across that much react
before is I am saying that I want to set
the flights with whatever I pass through
into here which is going to be flights
okay because the flights are whatever's
coming back from our Jason so
essentially all of this is our flights
and I'm passing it through into set
flights which is then going to pass that
onto the variable or the constant of
flights okay so that is how to use use
State and we're starting off with
flights being no so if I console log
flights
after fetching the data let's see what
happens we of course need to catch any
errors as well so catch error console
log error great
so this is looking good however we also
need to put this in a used effect so
what I'm going to do is put get flights
and use effect like so and not pass
through any
dependencies
so let's see what happens now let's go
to here
and
console
and there we go we get that Pax key
pesky cause messages and block by cause
so what I can do is go to my server and
use app again so app
use password calls and call it okay so
that is how you would get rid
of this pesky message so let's refresh
and great so this is why we have to use
use effect because the first time we get
the data that's null nothing and the
third time we get it the data is there
okay so that's all our flight data okay
so there's one object with its document
ID there's another object with this
document ID and so on and so on okay so
once again that is why we have the use
effect here so that we can keep running
this until we get our data right because
it came back as null now and then we got
it
wonderful
so now that we have our data let's use
it to populate some table rows
so let's do it
so this is obviously coming back in this
format as data so perhaps we can
actually
get the flights data and see what that
looks like so now this is our object our
object comes back with lots of other
little objects of course
so perhaps we need to format this we
want this to be an array essentially so
let's go ahead and do that
so I'm gonna have to get the object
values I think and turn them into an
array so how would I do this well let's
check it out so perhaps let's wrap this
an object
value so you can get the values
okay and there we go
so yes all I've done is look at this
object and say I don't want the key I
want the value instead and stick that in
an array for me and that's what happened
okay great so now I have an array of
five objects
wonderful so now that we have flights
like I said what I want to do is map
them so if flights exist I want to map
because as we know at the beginning it
returned back now right so if lights
exist I want to map that onto
so let's get the flight actually we need
the index too so the flight and the
index
because we need a key
and I essentially want to map them onto
the table
row component that we made
we're going to have a key for that as
that is necessary and we're just going
to pass through the flight so each
flight
okay
wonderful
so that is all I am doing I'm getting
the array and for each item in the array
I'm passing it through into the table
row element so now let's style the table
row element
which of course we need to also import
into here
so let's go ahead and do that import
table Row from table
row it's going to make it single quotes
to make everything consistent
wonderful
so let's get the table row and here we
go
so for now if I just console log
the flight which we are destructuring
okay we've destructured that prop
so I'm just going to console log the
flight now and look in here
we will get each individual flight
coming back okay so this is good let's
work with that so for each flight well I
actually don't need to do much
um I need to
just well I could just make a table cell
and then pass through each item of these
each value into a table cell so perhaps
no let's do that okay so return back
well actually with the table row let's
get the table row element
this is going to be made up of table
data so let's get the table data and
we're going to have
six of these with the first one actually
being this cute little airplane icon
that I found so feel free to take that
from my code if you wish and then for
each of the five remaining table data
elements we're going to have to well you
guessed it map out
each
of these okay so this is going to go on
one table cell this is going to go on
one table cell this is going to go on
one table sub
so let's import the table cell
import
table cell from table cell
want to get the I guess words I'm going
to use object
values again
to get the values
the object values of each flight so just
the ones in light green
so I'm going to pass through the flight
in here and just console log what this
looks like so we can see
let's have a look
okay and great as you'll see an array of
all the object values has been made for
us so now we can work with this array to
map them out onto table cells so let's
get the words
so words and if words exist I want to
map out each word
onto the
table cell of course we're going to have
to have a Q so I'm going to actually add
an index to this as well
so index
the index as a key and in fact I'm just
going to put this on another
line
there we go and the table cell is going
to have the key but it's also going to
have the word itself right so there we
go
great so that's what we're passing
through okay
cool
so now on the table cell
we're going to de-structure
the word and we can just return it I'm
going to show you what this looks like
if we just return the word
of course this needs to be in a table
data element and let's have a look at
what this looks like
it will look like this so This
essentially looks good however we want
to give it that flip effect right which
means we have to take this a step
further and for each word I want to
split it out by letter okay and then I
want to apply a timing effect to it so
let's go ahead and do that next so what
I'm going to do is well I am going to
instead of just putting the word in here
I'm going to essentially make an array
from the word
like so and then I'm going to map each
letter so let's get the letter and I'm
also going to use the index as a key and
what I'm going to do is just maybe get
rid of this now
is make a div this time and I'm going to
give it the class
name
of
well the class name is going to depend
because I want to add this class name
after X amount of seconds has passed
right so and I'm also going to pass
through the
letter
so at the moment if I look in here oops
let's just get rid of this for now
the letters are coming through let's
actually maybe just start this up a
little bit so they don't look like this
let's get our index CSS
and let's grab our departures grab our
table that lives inside of that and grab
the div so the div that I just created
and give each one a border
of solid
4 pixels and then the gray color
so just like that I'm going to give it a
border I'm also going to give each one a
background color of black essentially so
let's do that by rgb000
I'm also going to give each one amen
width of 20 pixels
and a height of 40 pixels so each list
is the same I'm going to make each one
float left
as well
so now if you look in here that's more
like it okay and then let's just make
this a little bit smaller for now
so there we go there we have our little
letters and of course we want to flip
them next
so let's go ahead and do that for this
I'm going to have to write an animation
okay so I'm going to create a class so
dot class called flip and I'm going to
make this an animation so animation
and on the last I want the animation to
last 0.5 seconds I want it to be smooth
so I'm going to add linear and I'm going
to define the keyframes of flipping
so at Key frames
flipping and all I'm going to say is at
the beginning of my 0.5 second animation
I want to transform rotate on the x-axis
start at zero degrees and then 50
through my 0.5 second animation I want
to transform and rotate X and I want it
to be to 90 degrees and then on 100 I
want to transform and just put it back
to zero
okay guys
okay so if I add the class of flip to
something essentially kick off this
animation
so this means that here I essentially
want to add the class a flip but add it
to each letter after X amount of time
has passed and for this I'm going to
have to use a set timeout
so I'm actually going to import use
state for this so we can save the flip
state for each of the letters so import
use state
from
react and I'm going to say const
flip set
flip
and then we're going to start off with
the flip being
false for each
div okay none of the divs have the
classic flip however I'm going to use
set timeout Now set time out
and I want this to set timeout to occur
after 100 milliseconds multiply by
whatever index we are looping over for
each word okay which means that we need
to go back into the table row and
actually pass through the index into
here too so the index of each word so
index I'm going to actually use the
index now so like so so on the table
cell I'm going to also pass through the
index and we're going to use it to
multiply to 100 milliseconds in order to
perform this set timeout after different
time intervals and what do I want to
have in this certain timeout I just want
to set flip to be
true
okay so I'm setting flip to be true by
using set flip it starts over being
false but then I set it to true so now I
can use flip in order to select a class
name
so I can say that if
flip is true I want to add the class of
flip otherwise
no there's no class name okay I'm
actually same for the Lesser same for
displaying the letter F lip exists then
I want to show the letter otherwise I
don't okay I just want to show an empty
string or we can just put it down
great so if we have a look now what this
looks like
ta-da wonderful so that is how it looks
we are essentially flipping out each
word we can of course take this a step
further and actually flip out each
letter so shall we do that yeah let's go
ahead so
instead of just creating this div here
I'm going to pass it through into
another component so let's go ahead and
create a new file uh let's call this
letter
table letter
just to keep everything consistent jsx
so now let's do const table letter
just like so and Export default table
letter
okay table letter and we know we already
need to pass through some things and
we're going to return
well we can actually just return
this right so I'm going to get one of
this
and put this as the return of the table
letter and then also this set timeout
doesn't want we don't want it to happen
here so let's grab all of that and put
it in here
which also means we need to import use
state which has been done for us
great
so now we just need to
map onto the table
letter
just like so and for each word we're
going to pass through the letter
as well as the index right so we're
going to use the index we're also going
to have to give this a key so I'm just
going to put this on a new line so it's
well
readable and of course we're gonna have
to
get up some
parenthesis and let's just put in a key
for good measure
and that'll be the index which actually
means we don't need to pass this through
into the table cell anymore from the
table row so let's get rid of that here
and let's get rid of that here I'm just
going to
do that again
okay because we're not using it so now
on the table letter is where the
flipping happens so that means that on
the table cell we're passing through the
letter and the index let's also go ahead
and import table
letter here from table letter
and on the table letter we're going to
pause with the word
and the index which were they going to
use to flip our
sorry letter and index
yeah the letter and index so which then
we're going to use the index to flip
each letter
which we have passed through into here
so now if we save this file
there we go now each letter is rotating
individually Okay so we've just taken
that a stepfather and there we go we
have essentially finished our widget
okay we've made it in reacts with a
database I hope you've enjoyed this
lesson and if you found this a little
bit difficult please watch my video or
make this in pure JavaScript and another
video we'll make this in JavaScript
using an API so there's three videos for
you all different all giving you the
same result but with different
Frameworks and approaches thanks very
much and I'll see you again soon